mi familia y yo nos hemos dedicado al
campo durante más de 70 años de hecho
podemos decir que mi hijo es tercera
cuarta generación de agricultor y si hay
una cosa que hemos aprendido de la
agricultura es que el negocio de la
agricultura es el rendimiento por
hectárea
en los 90s con la llegada del tratado de
libre comercio de américa del norte a
mexico los agricultores de esta tierra
nos pudimos dar cuenta de las grandes
ventajas que tiene nuestro campo
comparado con el campo norteamericano y
el campo canadiense para ellos su
invierno es muy largo y muy crudo y su
temporada de siembra es muy corta
y sí
la planta que más me gusta es el
cannabis
pero no me gusta no es mi planta
favorita porque se fuma sino porque es
una planta que tiene más de 25 mil
aplicaciones y como habíamos comentado
en la agricultura todo se basa en
rendimiento por hectárea de esta planta
podemos sacar alimentos podemos sacar
medicinas podemos sacar papel podemos
sacar plástico biocombustible concreto
al mismo tiempo que limpia los suelos
sus suelos y el medio ambiente
sin embargo tampoco soy el primer
aficionado a esta planta los primeros
rastros de esta planta los encontramos
en una pequeña aldea de lo que hoy
conocemos como taiwán y en la parte
medicinal los primeros rastros
encontramos en el año 4000 antes de
nuestra era en lo que hoy conocemos como
china de hecho podemos decir que el
cannabis fue una de las primeras plantas
en domesticadas ser domesticadas por el
ser humano y es una planta que lo ha
acompañado en toda nuestra historia de
hecho la primera imprenta la primera
biblia que fue impresa por guttenberg
fue impresa en papel de cáñamo
el cáñamo llega a américa con cristóbal
colón y no solo
en la tela de las velas de las tres
carabelas sino también en semilla para
sembrarse y de hecho henry ford hizo uno
de sus primeros automóviles hechos a
base de bioplásticos y con combustible
que estaba hecho a base de esta planta
sin embargo en esa misma época
carrey anslinger el director del
director de la oficina de narcóticos en
estados unidos buscaba un nuevo enemigo
público número uno ya que en esa época
se terminaba la prohibición del alcohol
y tenía miedo que su departamento se
fuera a quedar sin presupuesto y que
dijo
a qué le tienen miedo
los blancos norteamericanos y dijo muy
simple a los mexicanos ya los
afroamericanos y que fuman los mexicanos
y los afroamericanos marihuana que de
hecho es una palabra que se usa como un
despectivo hacia nosotros ya que no hay
nada más revolucionario mexicano que la
marihuana y lo podemos ver en las
canciones de la revolución que le
faltaba la cucaracha marihuana que fumar
en esa misma época se dan
la tormenta perfecta porque con la
revolución mexicana muchos compatriotas
salieron a buscar una nueva vida eeuu y
al mismo tiempo se daba el boom del jazz
a singer decide crear una campaña de
terrorismo racial en contra de los
mexicanos y los afroamericanos a través
de una gran maquinaria de propaganda
empezando por una película que se llama
reefer madness en la cual cuenta una
historia de cómo unos jóvenes se
suicidan y se matan a todos por fumar
cannabis
por esa misma época
un agrónomo de nombre de norman burló
que llegaba a ser sus primeros
experimentos a méjico
buscaba crear una nueva variedad de
trigo para acabar con el hambre mundial
hay que acordarnos que todos los panes
salen del trigo
y logra crear aquí en méxico una
variedad del trigo que es resistente
enfermedad es resistente al clima pero
principalmente con una con un gran
aprovechamiento industrial esto le
permitió a norman burló en el año de
1970 se le entregará el premio nobel de
la paz por la cantidad de gente que
salvó de que cayera en la hambruna a esa
época del mundo se le llamó la
revolución verde
ahora imagínense lo que haría para el
campo mexicano y para méxico la
industrialización de una planta de la
cual podemos obtener alimentos podemos
obtener fibras podemos obtener plásticos
podemos obtener papel podemos obtener
telas como hablábamos podemos obtener
más de 25.000 aplicaciones eso sería una
revolución verde 2.0
con la prohibición
el conocimiento milenario de esta planta
se llevó a guardarlo en los rincones más
obscuros del conocimiento humano hoy
gracias a la legalización
y poco a poco ha llegado a esta planta a
las universidades y los centros de
investigación más importantes del mundo
y gracias a eso en el año 2018 por
primera vez la rda registró una medicina
hecha a base de cannabis se llama 'pidió
lex y está hecha a base del cannabinoide
conocido como cvd es una medicina que
sirve para la epilepsia refractaria en
niños
para el año 2025 se espera que el
mercado del cannabis a nivel mundial
pueda llegar a valer al superar los 100
mil millones de dólares
esto para ponerlo en un contexto
méxico exporta un promedio de 50 mil
millones de dólares anuales en toda la
parte agroindustrial eso es de berries
de aguacates de cerveza de camarón de
carne o sea que esta industria nada más
para el año 25 va a valer el doble de lo
que valen todas las exportaciones a
nivel nacional y para ponerlo en una
forma más clara hoy méxico
y ocupa el primer lugar en producir
aguacate a nivel mundial producimos el
30 por ciento del aguacate del mundo lo
que nos da unas ventas anuales alrededor
de 2.500 millones de dólares esto
significa que sin méxico por su calidad
en el campo en el agua con su mano de
obra profesional que tiene pudiera
cubrir nada más el 10 por ciento de la
demanda del cannabis a nivel mundial
estaríamos hablando
que ese mercado valdría cuatro veces más
de lo que hoy vale el mercado del
algodón
porque los campesinos que producen maíz
de temporal están destinados a la
pobreza mientras una hectárea de maíz de
un agricultor de la sierra de guerrero
de sinaloa de michoacán de puebla
tiende a producir en un ciclo agrícola
no más de 10 mil pesos
el agricultor produce el maíz y no es de
que agarre ivaj y salga a vender ese
maíz ese maíz dulce de autoconsumo
y normalmente no tienen las
instalaciones necesarias para guardar el
maíz todo el año lo que genera que se
les echa a perder entonces imagínense
este pobre agricultor que sólo accede a
10 mil pesos en un año si transformará
su cultivo al cannabis al cáñamo
industrial principalmente podría obtener
con esa misma tierra con esa misma yunta
y con esos mismos bueyes
hasta 58 mil pesos por hectárea porque
como comentábamos esta puesta esta
planta es como el cuerpo te llevas todo
vendes la flor el fruto la raíces la
fibra y esto como volvemos a regresar al
tema es rendimiento por hectárea
economistas en finlandia dieron a
conocer que las dos grandes
oportunidades de esta planta se
encuentran principalmente en los
alimentos tanto para animales como para
seres humanos
como en sus fibras para la producción de
papel plástico y telas
y como dice el sabio proverbio popular
si usted quiere a sus hijos fuertes y
sanos póngalos mariguanos y esto es
porque el departamento de agricultura de
eeuu ya nombró a la semilla del game
como un superalimento o un super food
esto es un superalimento o un super food
por qué por qué es tan importante esta
semilla porque esta semilla produce los
nueve aminoácidos esenciales
para el ser humano además de que
producen mucho más omega 3 y omega 6 que
el atún que la chía y que la linaza
también sirve para alimento como para
alimentos como animales como habíamos
platicado las vacas que tienen
que comen cáñamo que tienen una mejor
digestión y eso hace que produzcan menos
gases y que sean menos dañinas para el
medio ambiente y también las gallinas
que comen cáñamo siempre ponen huevos
con omega 3 y omega 6
el año pasado méxico importó 20 millones
de toneladas de maíz amarillo para
consumo animal imagínense lo que sería
para la agricultura mexicana si
pudiéramos cubrir la mitad o una parte o
los 20 millones de toneladas de granos
que en lugar de que se tengan que
importar de eeuu se hicieran en mexico
que el dinero de esas 20 tantos 20
millones de toneladas se quedara en los
bolsillos de los agricultores mexicanos
y no de los agricultores norteamericanos
hoy uno de los retos más importantes que
tienen la humanidad es el plástico
todos los años se tiran 8 millones de
toneladas de plásticos a los océanos
esto significa que aunque cada minuto
que pasa de esta conversación un camión
de basura repleto de plásticos es tirado
a los océanos
una alternativa biodegradable a los
plásticos es el cáñamo no solo produce
alimentos sino hoy ya produce plásticos
hoy
esta etapa que ven aquí está hecho de
plástico hecho a base de caña
porque porque dentro de dentro la planta
el 70% de la planta celulosa y de esa
celulosa podemos sacar celuloide rayón o
celofán entre otros plásticos y no sólo
eso también es los plásticos hechos a
base de cáñamo son 3.5 veces más
resistentes
y cinco veces más ligeros que los
plásticos hechos a base de petróleo esto
ha hecho que marcas como bmw w
audi y mercedes benz ocupen ya estos
plásticos hechos a base de cáñamo para
la producción de plásticos para sus
coches y principalmente por una cosa
porque al ser mucho más ligeros
ocupan menos gasolina por lo tanto
contaminan menos pero eso no es la parte
más importante del plástico hecho a base
de caño porque mientras hoy una botella
hecha a base de pez tarda cientos de
años en descomponerse los plásticos
hechos a base de cáñamo industrial
pueden ser compostables en tan solo 180
días
actualmente el 42%
de la madera que se tala es para consumo
de papel imagínense que para crear para
crear un papel de baño tenemos que matar
un árbol que tardó décadas en crecer
el papel de cáñamo es el sustituto
perfecto
para el papel porque como comentábamos
mientras un árbol tarda 107 décadas en
crecer la planta del cáñamo está lista
en 120 días y por el clima que tiene
méxico esta misma planta la podemos
resembrar tres veces aparte de que una
hectárea de cáñamo produce lo que cuatro
hectáreas de pulpa de árboles para papel
y aparte también contiene sólo el 5% de
lignina lo que hace que el papel de
cáñamo sea más blanco y se pueda
reciclar más veces
otro de los grandes contaminadores del
planeta se llama el algodón el algodón
ocupa el 2.4 por ciento de la superficie
sembrada sin embargo ocupa el 16 por
ciento de los agroquímicos y el 6 por
ciento de los de los insecticidas
mientras que el cáñamo industrial ocupa
muy poco ya veces nada aparte el cáñamo
produce tres veces más fibra por
hectárea que el algodón y principalmente
una playera de cáñamo ocupa 20 veces
menos agua que lo que hoy ocupa una
playera de algodón es más hoy marcas
como patagonia y como lee vice están
están poniendo en su catálogo de
productos ya telas hechas a base de caña
por su gran compromiso con el medio
ambiente
y ahora sí
el cannabis es mi planta favorita
principalmente porque regenere el medio
ambiente
aquí es donde debemos de pensar que el
mundo no fue heredado por nuestros
padres fue prestado por nuestros hijos y
esta planta por la densidad que tiene al
ser sembrada es la planta que más
dióxido de carbono limpia del medio en
20 una toma una hectárea de caña puede
limpiar del medio en 20 entre 20 y 30
toneladas de co2
después de cosechado esta planta en sus
tejidos tiene 325 kilos de dióxido de
carbono
imagínense que para fabricar una
tonelada de cemento emitimos 900 kilos
de co2 hoy el ser humano debe de estar
pensando o está pensando en cómo borrar
esa huella de carbono la huella de
carbono es todo todo lo que va
contaminando paso a paso en su cadena
por en su cadena productiva cualquier
alimentos y de hecho el el concreto de
hecho a base de cáñamo conocido como gen
complete que sólo es más que las fibras
del cáñamo trituradas con cal y agua es
una planta que produce
de carbono negativo eso qué significa
que no sólo no contamina en su proceso
de fabricación sino que mientras está
mientras está viva es ese concreto sigue
limpiando el medio ambiente
estamos ante el renacimiento de una
nueva industria
donde la mayor oportunidad hoy se
encuentra en la investigación de esta
planta hoy méxico debería de estar
pensando cómo se va a convertir en el
principal productor de patentes
cannábicas médicas e industriales del
mundo
y hoy hoy la humanidad piensa en
colonizar marte donde las condiciones de
vida son extremas cuando deberíamos
estar pensando cómo vamos a incorporar
más productos del cáñamo industrial a
nuestra vida diaria muchas gracias